less than a year ago
Pluto was just a mess of pixels now New
Horizons has brought astonishing
resolution to the dwarf planet past data
dumps from New Horizons have teased us
with features like ice volcanoes and
slow flowing nitrogen ice med but now
scientists are making even more
startling findings from Pluto and its
largest moon Charon to start for such an
icy place there's new analysis that
suggests that Pluto has a warm interior
possibly due to radioactive decay which
has produced a tectonic landscape of
rocky ridges and Alpine mountains but
the Sun plays a role - solar winds beat
the planets methane and nitrogen
atmosphere pockmarking its surface and
producing clouds and haze scientists
think some of that lost atmosphere gets
trapped by gravity from Pluto's largest
moon Charon there it settles on the
moon's poles where it freezes and turns
red from radiation exposure of course
the gases could also come from Charon
tearing down its own surface like the
Hulk
good news interstellar Futurists pluto
has four of its own rocky moons that
could be perfect depots when we start
shuttling towards the Kuiper belt New
Horizons is already trailblazing that
route
next up Kuiper belt object 2014 mu 69 go
little probe go
[Music]